users will only see content that is
relevant to them that's what social
networks promise so what determines
which content is relevant social media
algorithms that work with user data the
most important data are likes which
topics does it user like does he or she
prefer videos or text which posts a
popular across the network
[Music]
algorithms use these data to select
posts friend individuals feed
conflicting opinions and too many
details are withheld from the user
according to experts an algorithm needs
around 300 likes to really know a user
[Music]
algorithms can also glean private
details users haven't shared on the
network like whether their parents are
divorced user data benefit something
else - targeted advertising which is a
profitable business for social networks
they add payed posts to the feed
selected according to user preferences
users can turn this pre selection off
and have post shown in chronological
order but that preference isn't saved so
the next time they log on they will
again see posts selected by an algorithm
using their data
[Music]